nein spaß leute also ich sehe mich
wirklich zum teil als vorbild und ich
versuche auch immer das so gut es geht
zu repräsentieren
aber ich bin trotzdem ich kann so leben
wie ich leben möchte und muss mich nicht
verstellen
das klappt jetzt willkommen bei nur ein
video
ja ich fange mal so an ich bin ja ein
mensch der auch vor allem auf instagram
wirklich sehr sehr aktiv ist falls sie
mir da noch nicht folgt kann ich das
wirklich nur jedem empfehlen ist ein
cooles soziales netzwerk ich bin da
wirklich sehr aktiv wie schon gesagt und
ich lese auch wirklich immer sehr viele
kommentare und es gibt bilder sind nicht
so viele kommentare und es gibt bilder
das sind sehr sehr viele kommentare
darunter die zum teil auch ja wie soll
ich sagen okay alex 30 zusammen jetzt
ehrlich gut flyer okay ich mache es kurz
ich hab letztens dieses bild hier
gepostet was ja weiß nicht also ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe überlegt ob
ich post aber ich hab mir gedacht komm
ich finde das bild schön so oder halt
cool und ich will halt wirklich immer
dass mein instagram account auch einen
schönen look hat so dass da nicht
irgendwie scheiße drauf ist sondern
coole bilder einzigartige bilder also
ich habe dieses bild dann halt
hochgeladen und dort mir so ach komm
dies jedoch meine kommentare durch und
dann hab ich gedacht ja die musste
einfach mal vorlesen so viele
kommentaren darunter die fand ich echt
lustig und zwar schreibt die liebe nina
auch ich dachte du brauchst nicht aber
schwer du postest und macht dann ein
video wurde die kommentare vor ließ oder
so weißt du dass bei dem kommentar habe
ich mir echt gedacht
schlaues mädchen spaß also um ehrlich zu
sein ich hatte nicht vor dazu ein video
zu machen aber wir gucken uns jetzt
einfach mal die weiteren kommentare an
und zwar schreibt philip neubauer genau
machen es den 10 jährigen zuschauern nur
vor dass die shisha rauchen solle nicht
wenn du jetzt sehen willst und das
du siehst doch shisha raucher zigaretten
ich hab neulich gesehen man kann sogar
tricks riegel rauchen viel spaß aber als
wenn irgendwelche zehnjährigen wegen mir
auf die idee kommen zu rauchen ich meine
ich sollte vielleicht mal kurz
klarstellen ich bin absoluter
nichtraucher was zigaretten angehen weil
ich da einfach keinen sinn dass ihr der
geschmack der gefällt mir überhaupt
nicht deswegen lass die finger von
aber ich finde es ist ganz normal dass
man mit 13 anfängt zu rauchen
dass man mit 16 auch mal china braucht
also heutzutage schon ab 13 aber ich
glaube ich habe das erst mal mit 16
dann kommen wir jetzt mal zu den
kommentar die sich am wenigsten unter
dem foto gehäuft haben und zwar schreibt
nicht carina ich könnte mich dann auch
vielleicht einfach mal umbenennt zu
nicht
manfred oder so weil ich bin ja nicht
manfred sondern alle im jahr tolle
vorbildfunktion und so okay du hast
recht also es wird ja wirklich oft
gesagt soja youtuber haben eine gewisse
vorbildfunktion die müssen ein vorbild
sein für ihre zuschauer
aber wenn ich mir gerade so die youtube
szene in deutschland anschaue baden in
tampons wer auch immer das gemacht hat
baden in spermien nicht was gab es da
habe ich noch nicht warum eigentlich
dann stelle ich mir wirklich die frage
hey sind youtuber wirklich vorbilder
nein spaß leute also ich sehe mich
wirklich zum teil als vorbild und ich
versuche immer das so gut es geht zu
repräsentieren
aber ich bin trotzdem ich kann so leben
wie ich leben möchte und muss mich nicht
verstellen wir zum nächsten kommentar
gutes vorbild alex ich mag deine videos
und dein charakter wie du dich in den
videos zeigt und so aber das sorry das
mal danke schön für das kompliment dass
du meine videos so gerne guckst mehr
wollte jetzt sitzt auch wer noch sorgen
kommen wir zum kommentar vom lieben denn
ist sonst fand ich dich immer cool habe
ich sogar auf youtube abonniert aber
zeit dem jetzt nicht mehr sorry aber was
ist eine sich an als wenn jemand
schluckauf hat nur leute mit werde ich
jetzt erst bewusst
ich hab jetzt einfach einen abonnenten
weniger kann er nicht sein
es hat alles keinen sinn mehr erst mal
eine shisha universum schreibt so jetzt
haben wir mal was die lobby nature zu
sagen haben recht ich verstehe die
aufregung einiger nicht meine mutter
raucht auf shisha aber keine zigaretten
heißt noch lange nicht dass er rauchen
muss er ist alt genug um zu wissen was
er tut dankeschön für das kompliment ich
bin alt genug da was zurecht ich stelle
mir gerade vor meine mutter würde shisha
rauchen einfach überhaupt nicht passen
deine mama soll machen was sie will ich
find's lustig mister blumen was her
es ist mir völlig egal ob du sagst du
rauchst nicht und dann brauchst du doch
ich finde es nur allgemein so
ekelerregend zu rauchen ich verstehe
einfach nicht warum manche sich dann so
geil fühlen ihr macht es doch alle nur
aus gruppenzwang oder damit euch alle
cool finden das ist wirklich armselig
das ist echt so also da kann ich auf
jeden fall die zustimmen also eigentlich
nicht es ist ganz normal dass wenn man
älter wird ab und zu mal einige dinge
ausprobiert und ich kann ganz ehrlich
sagen so wirklich fast alle von meinen
freunden rauchen zigaretten und ich bin
der einzige der keine zigaretten raucht
und shisha gefällt mir halt so dass ich
ab und zu mal vielleicht ein zweimal im
monat eine shisha raucher abends oder so
wenn ich halt langeweile haben das ist
kein gruppenzwang und ich mache das auch
nicht damit ich cool sein möchte weil
aus dem alter bin ich glaube ich auch
aus ach komm scheiß drauf ich hoffe das
video hat euch ein bisschen unterhalten
ihr könnt ihr aber in die kommentare
schreiben ob ihr zigaretten raucht ob
ihr shisha raucher ob ihr trick braucht
interessiert mich einfach mal deswegen
wie gesagt ich versuche das beste
vorbild zu sein was es gibt
aber ich finde um vorbild zu sein sollte
man sich auch nicht verstellen sondern
einfach zu sein wie man ist
das habe ich schon gesagt ich hoffe dass
wieder durch gefallen habe glaube ich
auch schon gesagt lassen doch nach oben
da würde mich wirklich sehr freuen
ansonsten kommen sonntag das nächste
video sonntag um 14 uhr dürft ihr auf
keinen fall verpassen
und ja ich wünsche einen schönen abend
verbringen hieß